back of course uh to uh the destruction
uh wrought on ukrainian towns and cities
by those relentless
attacks from russia the shelling and
airstrikes on those civilian areas has
been a tactic previously used by moscow
and chechnya and syria to try and break
the will of local populations the
ukrainian government has also accused
the russians of blocking aid supplies
trying to get into besieged cities and
refusing at humanitarian corridors we're
joined now by air marshal philip osborne
he's a former chief of defense
intelligence and a director at universal
defence and security solutions thank you
so much for being
uh with us we're
three weeks now into this invasion
what is the current state of putin's
troops
i think it's fair to say
um
they're
pretty demoralized pretty stuck and
they're pretty stalled actually
um they're demoralized because they were
poorly prepared uh and they've been
proven to be inadequate i think that's
putting it mildly
they're stalled because they've lost
momentum so we're seeing them pull
resources manpower from across russia
even from syria that's that's not a good
indication for a you know supposed
superpower
and they're still because they're
running out of options um and really
what's left to them now is to
is to double down on brute force um to
put pressure on the ukrainian government
you see this is the worry i guess isn't
it and that even if the ukrainian
resistance has been more than anyone
could have anticipated even if the
russian forces are demoralized
do you think it is brute force that
we're going to see more of
i think it is um
russia's tried to be
agile and that's failed it wasn't up to
it
so now it's faced with how does it how
does it get the ukrainian government to
settle on terms which are far more
favorable uh to to russia to putin i
mean this is all about putin
um and therefore the way they apply
apply pressure to the ukrainian
government
is to
you know level cities um to bring in
huge artillery um to try and generate
that humanity humanity and pressure just
not on the government but also on the
west
so
are you worried that putin could start
using
weapons that we don't usually see in in
these kind of fields of conflict um
chemical weapons for example even the
so-called like you know test of a
nuclear well how far could it go i think
i think we'll see more conventional
firepower first
um
russia has huge artillery stocks
um and this is now a long drawn-out
conflict and they can be devastating as
well right exactly right um so
so we will see lots of conventional
but the risk of more unconventional
whether it be chemical whether it be bio
whether it be even nuclear that risk
must be higher um we come back to putin
does have doesn't have many military
options and they're his therefore his
options to escalate on narrower
and of course this has an impact on how
the west responds
it does um
the west the west has got a challenge um
it has got to strike the balance between
trying to deter behavior
without
excessively escalating so this is a
really difficult tight rope to walk
but
but we have to be strong we have to be
resolute putin
does not respect weakness he sees us as
weak he sees us
decadent he knows every time he pushes
us we take a step back
so he will have been surprised by
um
the overwhelmingly strong sanctions that
have been leveled against him he'll be
surprised by the willingness of the west
to support the ukrainian government and
their armed forces but it's not enough
so there's something about the west
needing to reset what it means about
strength and resolution in order to
deter further aggression so what does
that mean in practical terms what do you
think we should do
so there's a thing for the uk and
there's a thing for for the west more
broadly um the west needs to be
needs to be less trivial it needs to be
more strategic it needs to be more
resolute in the way that we've seen over
the last few weeks but we weren't seeing
over the previous 10 15 20 years
i think the integrated review from a uk
perspective is a good start
um but what this demonstrates is that
security isn't about sound bites it's
about doing difficult things
and being
focused on maintaining those difficult
things so
so the integrated review
yes is a good start we need more mass
and capability that's probably
more in the unmanned space probably um
we certainly need more
um digital capabilities and we and we
need really as a nation to be more
resilient
that's both physically can we defend
ourselves
in the virtual space can we are we good
at cyber resilience but also in in the
way we are you know the strength of our
society what what do we feel
the most important thing though is is
we've got to go quickly this this is a
wake-up call when we look at the
integrated review it has a 10-year
horizon that is too long do we need more
money it was interesting when i spoke to
the chancellor earlier he was just
talking about the money that he'd
already given to the ministry of defense
and i got the very clear impression that
we shouldn't expect any more
um and
the the chancellor will make the
decisions that he needs to make if you
ask somebody who did
nearly 40 years
in the uk military
sinusoidal application of investment is
no good for it
so it needs
sustained investment
to allow us to protect the nation
but also from a uk military point of
view to take his part in a far more
strengthened nato
for germany to commit 100 billion euros
in one year
i think indicates the scale of the
challenge that all western nations
follow and the uk i'm sure would want to
play as part
um i just want to
uh draw us back to the situation that
we're seeing unfolding in ukraine
the bombardment has been pretty
relentless and it seems that we should
expect more of the same how long
realistically do you think the
ukrainians can withstand this um
they have been amazing
but we need to bear in mind that they
they've been preparing for this this for
most of the west started three weeks ago
for ukraine this started nearly a decade
ago
um
so they've had time to prepare to think
it's that resilience that i was talking
about
um
they've also got a strength of will
and the application of good weaponry
which i think we're seeing
um frankly i think they will hold out as
long as
we can supply them and as long as their
morale holds up and those are two very
easy things to say
but really challenging to do but
focusing on supporting a brave people do
what's right for them has to be one of
those things that the west does to show
strength and resolution and president
zielenski has said that it's time to
talk he's called on russia to get around
the table and to try and find a
diplomatic solution and in the uk our
foreign secretary liz trust has
effectively said she doesn't trust
russia she thinks it could be a smoke
screen to allow russia to regroup and
then carry out more attacks
what is your sense about how optimistic
you are that any of these talks could
actually lead to some kind of solution
i'm quite pessimistic in the short term
two things have to line up
ukraine has to be comfortable to give
something up
which to be honest with our interview
with the ukrainian deputy prime minister
she said that that was absolutely off
the table and you can understand why
that's the case because
thousands of ukrainians are laying down
their lives as we speak for that for
that sense of self so the
what is ukraine prepared to give up and
what is putin prepared to accept from
the perspective of a paranoid individual
until those two things get close
then there won't be an agreement
and i can't see those things getting
close soon
i understand the pessimism um that you
have
just finally ukraine is also asking for
other countries to effectively act
as security guarantors for any peace
deal so effectively if they end up
agreeing to not join nato and they sign
some kind of deal they want the
assurance that they will be backed up if
russia tries to invade again in the
future or so on
do you think the uk should be prepared
to give that assurance to ukrainian and
what would that mean
oh the ukraine has a security guarantee
already it was given in 1994 by the us
the uk and russia
and where are we now
so if i was a ukrainian i'd want to be
really clear that those security
guarantees were cast iron and more cast
iron than they were 20 years ago yeah
those type of things i'm sure will have
to be part of a solution
but if i was a ukrainian i'd want to see
the color of people's money and that
brings you back to
resolution and meaning what you say not
going through the motions
really interesting to talk and thank you
so much for being on the programme today